you write about social justice you write
about two kinds of social justice
liberal social justice and uh sjf social
justice fundamentalism what are those
yeah so like the term wokeness is so
loaded with baggage it's kind of like
mocking and derogatory and that's I was
trying not to do that in this book
um if it's the terms of little bit
baggage you're already kind of you're
you're from from the first minute you're
already behind
um so
to me uh it also that when it when
people say wokeness is bad social
justice is bad they're throwing the baby
out with the bathwater
um because the the pro you know the
proudest tradition in the U.S is liberal
social justice and what I mean by that
again liberal meaning lowercase l
it is it is intertwined with liberalism
so Martin Luther King Classic example
his I Have a Dream speech he says stuff
like this country you know
is you know has has made a promise
to all of its citizens and it has broken
that promise to to its black citizens
right
in other words liberalism the
Constitution the core ideals those are
great we are not living up to them we're
failing on some of them so Civil
Disobedience the goal of it wasn't to to
hurt liberalism is to specifically break
the laws that were already violating
Liberty that were the laws that were a
violation of liberalism to expose that
this is illiberal that the constitution
should not have people of different skin
colors sitting in different parts of the
bus and so it was it was kind of a it
was really patriotic you know the Civil
Rights Movement was saying this is a
beautiful you know we have a we have a
liberalism is this beautiful thing and
we need to do better at it so I call it
liberal social justice and it used the
tools of liberalism to try to uh
to try to uh improve the flaws and that
we're going on so free speech you know
Mario Savio in the 60s was a you know
he's a leftist and what would the
leftists doing in the 60s on Berkeley
campus you know they were saying we need
more free speech
um because that's what social liberal
social justice was fighting for it but
you can also go back to the 20s women in
suffrage I mean so the the you know the
Emancipation the the thing that America
obviously has all of its these These are
these are all ugly things that it had to
get out of but it got out of them you
know one by one and it's still getting
out of them that's what's cool about
America and liberal social justice
basically is the practice of saying
where are we not being perfect liberals
and now let's fix that
so that that's the idea of liberalism
that permeates the history of the United
States but then there's interplay
Heavenly and so many good images in this
book but one of them is uh is
highlighting the interplay of different
ideas over the past uh let's say 100
years so liberalism is on one side
there's that thread there's Marxism on
the other and then there's postmodernism
how do those interplay together so it's
interesting because
Marxism
is and all of its various you know
descendants obviously there's a lot of
things that are rooted in Marxism that
aren't you know the same thing as what
Karl Marx preached but what do they all
have in common
they think liberalism is bad right they
actually think that
um
that the opposite of what Martin Luther
King and other people uh in the Civil
Rights and other movements they think
the opposite they think he thinks you
know liberalism is good we need to
preserve it they said liberalism is the
problem these other problems with racism
and inequality that we're seeing those
are inevitable results of liberalism
liberalism is a rigged game and it's
just the power games in Disguise there
is no liberal games it's just the power
games in Disguise and there's the upper
people that oppress the lower people and
they convince the lower people is all
about false consciousness they convince
the lower people that everything is fair
and now the lower people vote against
their own interests and they and they
work to preserve the system that's
oppressing them and what do we need to
do we need to actually there's much more
revolutionary we need to overthrow
liberalism right so people think is oh
you know like what we call a wokeness is
just you know a normal social justice
activists activism but it's like more
extreme right it's this no no it's the
polar opposite polar opposite and so
um now that's that's the Marxist threat
now post-modernism is kind of you know
this term that is super controversial
and I don't think anyone calls
themselves a post-modernist or take all
this with a grain of salt in terms of
the term but what's the definition of
radical the definition of radical to me
is how deep you want change to happen at
so so um a liberal Progressive
and and a conservative Progressive will
disagree about policies the liberal
Progressive wants to you know change a
lot of policies and change change change
right and the conservative is more wants
to keep things the way they are
but they're both conservative when it
comes to liberalism
um beneath it the liberal kind of
foundation of the country they both
wanted they both are become
conservatives about that the Marxist is
more radical because they want to go one
notch deeper and actually overthrow that
Foundation now what's below what's below
liberalism is kind of the core tenets of
modernity
um this idea of reason and
um the notion that there is an objective
truth and
um uh science as the scientific method
right these things are actually beneath
and even the Marxist if you look at the
Frankfurt School you know these these
these these post Marxist thinkers and
and Marx himself they were not
anti-science they believed in that
bottom bottom Foundation they were they
were they were they were actually wanted
to preserve modernity but they wanted to
get rid of liberalism on top of it the
post-modernist is even more radical
because they want to actually go down to
the bottom level and overthrow they
think science itself is a tool of
Oppression they think it's a tool uh
where oppression kind of flows through
you know they think that the white
Western world has invented these
Concepts like you know they claim that
there's an objective truth and that
there's you know reason in science and
they think all of that is just one meta
narrative and right and it and it goes a
long way to serve the interests of the
powerful so in the sense that so it's
almost caricatured but that is to the
core of their belief that math could be
racist for example oh yeah absolutely
not the educational math but literally
math the notion in math that there's a
right answer and a wrong answer that
they believe is a meta-narrative that
serves white supremacy or in in in the
post-modernists might have said it
serves just the powerful
um or the wealthy but to so what social
justice fundamentalism is is you take
the Marxist thread that has been going
on in lots of countries and has and and
whoever the upper and lower is that's
what they all have in common but the
upper and lower you know and for for
Marx was the ruling class and the
oppressed class it was economic
um and then uh but you come here and and
the economic class doesn't you know
doesn't resonate as much here as it did
maybe in some of those other places but
what does resonate here in the 60s and
70s is race and gender and these kind of
social justice disagreements and so what
social justice fundamentalism is is
basically this this tried and true
framework of
you know this Marxist framework
kind of with a new skin on it which is
American social justice and then made
even more radical with the infusion of
post-modernism where you know not just
as liberalism bad but actually the sign
you know that like you said math can be
racist so it's this kind of like
philosophical Frankenstein this like
stitched together of these it and has
and and so again it's called you you
know they wear the same uniform as the
liberal social justice they say social
justice right you know Racial equality
but it has nothing to do with liberal
social justice it is directly opposed to
Liberal social justice this is
fascinating the evolution
of ideas if if we ignore the harm done
by it it's fascinating how humans get
together and involve these ideas so as
you show Marxism is the idea that
Society is a zero-sum I mean I guess
zero sum is a really important thing
here uh zero-sum struggle between the
ruling class and the working class with
power being exerted through politics and
economics then you add
critical theory Marxism 2.0 on top of
that and you add to politics and
economics you add culture and
institutions and then on top of that for
postmodernism you add science you have
morality basically anything else you can
think to stitch together Frankenstein
and if you notice and which is not
necessarily bad but in this case I think
it's actually violating the Marxist
tradition by being anti-science and and
you know and it's violating the
post-modernism because what
post-modernists were they were Radical
Skeptics not just of they were Radical
Skeptics not just of the way things were
but of their own beliefs they they and
what and social justice fundamentalism
is suddenly is not at all uh self self
critical it says that we have the
answers which is the opposite of what
post-modernists would ever say this no
you just have another meta-narrative so
and it's also violating of course the
tradition of like liberal social justice
in a million ways because it's it's
anti-liberal
um and so this Frankenstein comes
together meanwhile liberal social
justice doesn't have a Frankenstein it's
very clear it's very it's a crisp
ideology that says we need we are trying
to make we're trying to get to a more
perfect union they're trying to to to
keep the promises made in the
Constitution and that's what it's trying
to do and so it's it's much simpler in a
lot of ways so you write that my big
problem with social justice
fundamentalism isn't the ideology itself
it's what it's Scholars and activists
started to do sometimes around 2013 when
they began to wield a Kajol that's not
supposed to have any place in the
country like the US so it's the actions
not the ideas
I don't like the ideology I think it's a
low rung ideology I think it's morally
inconsistent based on you know it
flip-flops on on its morals depending on
the the group I think it's Echo chambery
I think it's um I I think it's it's it's
full of inaccuracies and kind of can't
stand up to debate so I think it's a lot
but but there's a ton of lowering
ideologies I don't like I don't like a
lot of religious doctrines I don't like
a lot of political doctrines right
the U.S is a place inherently that is a
mishmash of a ton of ideologies and I'm
not gonna like two-thirds of them at any
given time so my problem the reason I'm
writing about this is not because I'm
like by the way this ideology is not
something I like that's not interesting
the reason that it must be written about
right now this particular ideology is
because
it's not playing nicely with others what
what I if you want to be a hardcore you
know Evangelical Christian go in the US
says Live and Let Live not only are you
allowed to to have an echo chamber of
some kind you're it's actively protected
here Live and Let Live they can do what
they want you do what you want now if
the Evangelical Christians started
saying by the way anyone who says
anything that conflicts with even
Evangelical Christianity is going to be
severely socially punished and they have
the cultural power to do so which they
don't in this case they might like you
but they don't have the power but
they're I'd be able to get anyone fired
who they want and they're able to
actually change the curriculum in all
these schools in class to to suddenly
not conflict with no more evolution in
the in the textbooks because they don't
want it now I would write a book about
why about Evangelical Christianity
because that's what every liberal
regardless of what you think of the
actual horizontal beliefs
doesn't matter what they believe when it
when they start violating Live and Let
Live
and shutting down other area other
segments of society and in kind of it's
almost like a you know not to you know
it's not the best analogy but like it's
like a a Neco chamber is like a benign
tumor and what you what you have to
watch out for is a tumor that starts to
metastasis that starts to forcefully
spread and damage the tissue around it
and that's what this particular ideology
has been doing do you worry about it you
know as an existential threat
to to liberalism in in the west in the
United States
is it a problem or is it
the biggest problem that's threatening
all of human civilization it's I I would
never I would not say it's the biggest
problem it it might be I wouldn't if
someone if it turns out in 50 years
someone says actually it was I wouldn't
be shocked
but I also I would I wouldn't bet on
that because there's a lot of problems
I'm a little sorry to interrupt it is
popular to say that kind of thing though
and it's less popular to say the same
thing about AI or nuclear weapons which
worries me that I'm more worried about
nuclear weapons even still than I am
about wokeism so I've gotten I've had
probably a thousand arguments about this
that's one nice thing about spending six
years procrastinating on getting a book
done is you end up test battle testing
your ideas a million times so I've heard
this one a lot right which is
there's kind of three groups of former
Obama voters one is super woke now yeah
another one is super anti-woke now and
the third is what you just said which is
sure Wellness is over the top right
they're not you're not woke but
I think that the Andy woke people are
totally lost their mind and it's just
not that big a deal right
now here's why I disagree with that
because
it's not it's not wokeness itself
it's that
a of radical
um political movement of which there
will always be a lot in the country
has managed to do something that a
radical movement is not supposed to be
able to do in the U.S which is they've
managed to
hijack
institutions all across the country and
medical journals and universities and
you know the ACLU you know saying all
the you know activist organizations and
non-profits and and certain ngos yeah
and many and many tech companies and
what so it's not that I think this thing
is so bad it's a little like we said
with Trump it's that what I'm what's the
reason Trump scares me is not because
Trump's so bad it's that because it
shows it's it reveals that we were
vulnerable to a demagogue candidate and
what wokeness reveals to me is that we
are currently and until something
changes will continue to be vulnerable
to a
um
a bully a bully movement and a
forcefully expansionist movement that
wants to actually
um
destroy the workings inner their liberal
gears and tear them apart and so so
here's the way I view a liberal
democracy is it is that it is is a bunch
of these institutions that were that
were trial and error crafted over you
know hundreds of years
and they all rely on trust public trust
and there's certain kind of feeling of
unity that that actually is critical to
a liberal democracy's functioning and
with I see this thing is as a parasite
on that that whose goal is and I'm not
saying by the way each individual in
this is I don't think they're bad people
I think that it's it's the ideology
itself has the property of its goal is
to tear apart the pretty delicate
workings of the liberal democracy and
Shred the critical lines of trust
and so you talk about Ai and you talk
about all these other big problems
nuclear right the reason I I like
writing about that stuff a lot more than
I like writing about politics this was a
fun topic for me is because I realized
that like all of those things if they're
gonna have a good future with those
things and they're actually threats like
I said we need to have a wits about us
and we need the the liberal you know
gears and and levers working we need the
liberal machine working and so if
something's threatening to undermine
that it affects everything else
we need to have our scientific mind
about us about these foundational ideas
but I I guess my sense of hope comes
from observing the immune system respond
to wokism
there seems to be a pro-liberalism
immune system
and not only that so like there's
intellectuals there's people that are
willing to do the fight you talk about
courage are being courageous and there
is a hunger for that such that those
ideas can become viral and they take
over so I just don't see a mechanism by
which wokism
accelerates like exponentially and takes
over like is expand it feels like as it
expands the immune system responds uh of
the the the immune system of the of
liberalism of of basically a country in
at least the United States that's still
ultimately at the core of the individual
values the freedom of speech Just
freedoms in general the freedom of an
individual but that's the battle
so to me it is like a virus and an
immune system yeah and
I totally agree I see the same story
happening and I you know I'm sitting
here rooting for the immune system oh
you're still worried well here's the
thing so a liberal democracy is in
always going to be vulnerable to a
movement like this right and there will
be more because it's not a totalitarian
dictatorship because if you can socially
pressure people to not say what they're
thinking you can suddenly start to just
take over right you can break the
liberalism of the liberal democracy
quite easily and suddenly a lot of
things are illiberal
on the other hand
the same vulnerability the same system
that's vulnerable to that also is hard
to truly conquer
because now the maoists
right similar kind of vibe they were
saying that science is evil and as a you
know and that they're the intellectuals
are you know it's all it's all this big
conspiracy
but they could murder you
and they had the hard cudgel in their
hand right and the hard cudgel
is scary and
um and and you can conquer a country
with the hard cudgel but you can't use
that in the U.S so what they have is a
soft cudgel which can have the same
effect
initially you can scare people into
shutting up you can't maybe imprison
them and murder them but if you can
socially ostracize them and get them
fired that basically is going to have
the same effect so the soft cudgel can
have the same effect for a while but the
thing is
it's it's a little bit of a house of
cards because it relies on fear and as
soon as
that fear goes away
the whole thing falls apart right the
soft cultural requires people to be so
scared of getting canceled or getting
whatever and as soon as some people
start you know Toby lutka of Shopify I
always like think about you know he just
said you know what I'm not scared of
this soft cudgel and spoke up and said
we're not political at this company and
we're not a family we're a team and
we're going to do this and you know what
like
they're thriving you will be on this
podcast his seems like a fascinating
human he's amazing he spoke up he's one
of the smartest and like kindest dudes
but he's also
um he has courage at a time when it's
hard but here's the thing is that it's
different than that you need so much
less courage against a soft cudgel than
you do the Iranians throwing their
hijabs Into the Fire those people's
courage just just blows away any courage
we have here because they might get
executed
that's the thing is that you can
actually have courage right now and it's
so
don't worry about it
um
oh man the irony of that and you talk
about so two things to fight this
there's two things awareness and courage
what's the awareness piece
the awareness piece is
um
is is under first just no understanding
the stakes
like getting our heads out of the sand
and being like technology is blowing up
exponentially we're our society's trust
is devolving like we're kind of falling
apart in some important ways we're
losing our grip on some stability at the
worst time
that's the first point just the big
picture and then also awareness of I
think this vertical axis or whatever
your version of it is this concept of
how do I really form my beliefs where do
they actually come from where you know
did they are they someone else's beliefs
am I following a checklist
um how about my values you know I used
to identify with the blue party or the
red party but now they've changed and
and I suddenly am okay with that is that
because my values changed with it or am
I actually anchored to the party not to
any principle asking yourself these
questions
um asking your you know looking for
where do I feel disgusted by fellow
human beings you know that maybe I'm I'm
being a crazy tribal person without
realizing it how about the people around
me am I being bullied by some Echo
chamber without realizing it
um am I the bully somewhere right so
that's the first just just I think just
to kind of do a self-audit and and and
um and I think that like just just some
awareness like that it's just a
self-audit about these things can can go
a long way but if you don't if you keep
it to yourself it's almost useless
because if it doesn't if you don't have
without you know awareness without
courage does very little so courage is
when you take that awareness and you
actually export it out into the world
and it starts affecting other people and
so courage can happen on multiple levels
it can happen by first of all just stop
saying stuff you don't believe if you're
being pressured by a kind of a ideology
or a movement to say stuff that you
don't actually believe just stop just
just just stay in your ground and don't
say anything that's that's courage
that's one first step
start speaking out in small groups
starts you know actually speaking around
see what happens the sky doesn't usually
fall actually people usually respect you
for it like you know and it's not not
every group but like you'd be surprised
and then eventually you know maybe start
speaking out in bigger groups start
going public you know Global go public
with it but and you don't need everyone
doing this look some people will lose
their jobs for it I'm not talking to
those people most people won't lose
their jobs but they have the same fear
as if they would right and it's like
what are you gonna get criticized or are
you gonna get a bunch of people you know
angry Twitter people will will criticize
you like it yeah it's not pleasant but
actually that's a little bit like our
primitive Minds fear that really
back when it was programmed that kind of
ostracism or criticism will get leave
you out of the tribe and you'll die
today it's kind of a delusional fear
it's not actually that scary and the
people who have realized that can
exercise incredible leadership right now